mentorship is not something you ask
somebody to do so look for mentors who
don't necessarily give you answers I for
years read books of people who I didn't
know but I considered them with my
personal Mentors what's that believe
nation it's having my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world
now I started the one rule series
because we do a lot of top tens and
there's a lot of rules that come up over
and over and over again and the one rule
series smush is the most popular rules
together into one super clip for you so
today we're gonna learn how you can find
mentors enjoy
[Music]
here's what I've learned about
mentorship mentorship is not something
you ask somebody to do like will you be
my friend it doesn't work like that when
you find somebody you get along with you
share values your shared beliefs you
spend time with them you get to know
them you develop trust you take us
you're vulnerable with them you open up
to them and you discover that you become
friends it's what happens you start off
as simply acquaintances in my experience
mentorship is exactly the same there
were people who were much more
experienced than me who had wisdom that
I didn't have and I when I would call
him they would take my calls
and when I would ask them questions they
would always take the time to give me
answers and over the course of time they
became my mentors like they became my
friends and I remember one time I was
with one of my mentors Ron brooder an
amazing guy and I was leaving his house
and I put my arm around him I said you
know I'm glad you're my mentor and he
looked at me and he said I'm glad you're
mine and it caught me completely
off-guard and true mentorship like true
friendship is not a one-way street
it's not about one person only giving
advice the other both people are showing
up to give and both people are showing
up to learn but you kind of someone to
be your mentor especially someone who's
a total stranger knock on their door and
say will you be my mentor if they don't
know you you've never met them it's like
friendship you cultivate a relationship
and if that person is always there for
you and wants to see you thrive and
succeed and believes in you then perhaps
they will become your mentor like making
a friend you've mentioned that you
you've been lucky enough to have mentors
in your life such as Anna Wintour the
editor of Vogue Arianna Huffington
Johnny I've of Apple I'm notorious for
just cold calling people in you know
just pick up the phone call them up and
let's just talk you know there's nothing
in particular
I just want to talk and just you know
explain to me how you see your business
you know how do you operate the business
you know Johnny Ives in particular he's
just fascinating
his process of creating design and when
I was playing I used what I did that I
used to try to connect the dots between
how John Williams would compose a score
for a film or Johnny eyes would design
new Apple product and how does that
connect to how I play the game of
basketball is there's something there
that I can learn that can be used when I
step out here on the court there's
lessons that surround us I mean it life
is basically a library you just fit you
know all we need to do is just open our
eyes and look and and ask and read
accordingly so is that something you
were doing you were building those
relationships even but outside of your
interest as a businessman really it even
as an athlete and a basketball player
yeah it means the curiosity I think the
curiosity is the most important thing I
mean it's it's you know it's sounds
really weird to say but it made like
leadership lessons I learned leadership
lessons just from walking in the park is
just observing nature and the sun's
relationship with nature and
relationship with the moon and the Sun
understanding when to be present and
when they go away right because as a
teammate it was like dude the sun's out
all damn long you're gonna sunburn a
hell of a lot of people right so if I'm
playing this game and I'm on top of my
guys for 48 minutes dude you're gonna
sunburn every single team made there
okay so the certain times was important
for the Sun to be present as other times
it needs to go away
right and but their life less is s
around us at all times and I've always
been extremely extremely curious about
those things very frequently we'll ask
someone for instance what advice would
you give to a 30 year old just getting
started here in your industry what is
the best advice you would give and just
as important I think you should ask what
advice should that person ignore or what
is the worst advice that you hear
repeated often in your industry what is
the conventional wisdom that you
disagree with those type of questions
give you a not to do list and it is what
you don't do that provides the space for
what you can do
anyone who says you should do this the
way I did it without any caveats
be may be ignored in many cases but
certainly viewed with suspicion the the
type of mentors who tend to be the most
helpful or those who don't necessarily
give you an answer but they give you a
better way of finding that answer I'm
leaving my second job I want to start my
own company what should I do
and they say well I can't tell you what
you should do because I don't have
enough information which is a huge
credibility point in my mind that they
have the awareness to say that and they
said but if I were in your position
here's how I might think through it so
look for mentors who don't necessarily
give you answers but who walk you
through the process of how they might
think about making the proper decision
given all of your particulars and I
think that's what in my experience
separates a mediocre or decent mentor
from a great mentor you have with you on
some of you head with you on this Larry
Moss who was yeah great acting terrific
absolutely and as good as you are
and knowing you self as well as you do
what does someone like that bring to you
like the knowledge knowledge and also
you know support absolutely when you go
into new areas you know you you you you
like to be mentored in certain ways I
mean I'm not too old for a mentor and
and he certainly did that I never get
too old for a mentor absolutely not you
know I think I think it's you never get
too old to learn something new and when
Frank came to my house and he said he
said Jim I know you're a home run hitter
but now you have to learn a new swing
yeah and and I said you know meaning
you're not swinging for the fence
perhaps and a baseball metaphor or not
necessarily swinging doing the sacrifice
fly or you know whatever whatever you
have to do and and I was just - game I
was I was into it I love it I love I
love the idea that at my age I can learn
something new and go into a different
area and what do you say to someone
while saying oh nobody around me
believing in me and that's okay if you
have that that's great if you don't have
it yeah it's okay I for years read books
people who I
didn't know but I considered them in my
personal mentors I I said it Winston
Churchill who said the truth is contrary
incontrovertible malice mere tacit
ignorance they derided but at the end
there it is I said it Earl Nightingale
who said all of us get in life what we
are not what we want all of us are
self-made but only the successful will
admit it so I studied these people and
they mentor to me I feel their spirit
sigh I surrounded myself in my bid with
their dignity and their law do in my
imagination and listening to their audio
programs yes
so how much the library call card costs
it's free in the United States I don't
know what in your country so I suggest
that you spend time working on yourself
study the high achievers I did that to
find out how did they get there I study
the life of Frederick Douglass who say
we won't get everything that we fight
for but everything we get it will be a
fight and so as you study these people
and imagine yourself in their position
and in your minds I say to yourself as I
did if they can do it I can do it they
put their pants on one leg at a time
they breathe air just as I do and so I
believe that what you would you focus on
the longest becomes a strongest what we
think about we bring about when you
train your mind to serve you yes by
reading a minimum of 20 to 60 pages a
day listening to audio programs writing
goes down reaching reading them three
times a day
you're literally creating a new mental
blueprint and imagining and seeing
yourself already living from the goal
you begin to do some things that would
most people look at it and see is
magical you had an early meeting with
Dino De Laurentiis and it didn't go so
well
what that was different because Dino De
Laurentiis had an office and he wanted
me to be in dark savage and he wanted me
to play the villain in dark savage and I
walked in and I always kind of you know
have a mouth that sometimes goes a
little bit too fast and the step myself
the I walked into the office and they're
so Dino standing behind
desk and there was this huge desk ornate
gold and kind of like French looking or
Italian looking I don't know what but it
was gigantic it was one of this partner
desk right and Dino the only thing that
stood out was kind of his chest and his
head because he's a little guy Dean
there's a really short so I looked in
and I walked in his office and I looked
in his his hi Tina
why does a little guy like you need such
a big desk and too thin of the
horrendous you never say you little
right because he saw himself as a giant
so he looked at Minnie says ah I smarts
in Agra you have an accent I cannot use
it you yeah and I said again stupidly
who was talking about having an accent I
mean listen to you are you a Nazi you
know he walked away because I the German
accent said that was the end of them so
I left the office and my agent came up
to me grabbed me really forceful with my
arm and he said to me says I have been
an agent for 15 years this meeting was
exactly one minute and 14 seconds it was
the shortest meeting they've ever had
you just everything up got them and it
took me months to get in here so he was
mad at me also so anyway so that's so
that's how the relationship started with
Dina but then when he bought Conan he
came to Spain where we were shooting and
the third day of filming after so the
dailies the footage should be a film he
came up to me and said there's rats in
Agra you're Conan ah and he walked off
and and Milius came to me the director
says this is the greatest compliment
that he can ever get he said you're
Conan
isn't that great yeah I guess so and
from that point on we created this
really great relationship and we did
movies together and raw deal and then
red Sonia and Conan the Destroyer and
Conan of appearance and and there he was
became kind of like a father figure he
became caliph the red
park that I had in a bodybuilding world
in Joe Weider he became that character
in a movie world that I could go to for
anything who would give me advice who
always had wonderful compliments and
kind of took me in as part of his family
and so that's why I always will miss him
very dearly after they passed away I'm a
big believer in mentorship one in terms
of you know face to face people that you
can go and learn from and to from what I
call aspirational mentors people who've
done a lot more than you who you may
never meet who may have passed on but
you can still learn from their success
it comes from the core understanding
that whatever challenge you have in
front of you right now somebody else has
already solved it whatever big problem
you're facing in your life or in your
business somebody has already solved it
and you don't need to come up with every
ingenious solution yourself this is one
of the things that saved my first
business one of the two most important
lessons that I've ever learned in my
life was whenever I don't know what to
do we never have a big problem I don't
know the answer I look for somebody who
has already solved it and I try to learn
from their lessons in my first business
I had a software company I was
struggling you know making $300 a month
barely able to survive and I was just
trying to come up with all these ideas
myself like okay how about we do this
how we do this how many and nothing was
working and I told my partner I quit and
it was the worst day of my life and when
I woke up the next day I realized I
didn't want to quit I just couldn't keep
going the way I was going and the
lightbulb moment was I realized I'm not
the first guy to try to sell software
before maybe our specific kind of
software yes but in general other people
have figured out how to sell software
and make lots of money and target lots
of customers how did they do it and I
looked at Bill Gates and how he got
started and that started the process to
me be able to build a real company and
that lesson that I learned that 19 years
old has stayed true for the past almost
20 years where every time I don't know
what to do and look at who can I model
it's it's why the name of this channel
is modeling the Masters it's why I try
to showcase lots of different successful
people from all walks of life because
you can learn from them I'm learning
that is there anyone director who you
kind of linked into is your idea of how
the director is it at the combination of
all these different pretty people you
take things I think from everybody you
know you kind of see what would work for
you and what would in and honestly I've
you know there's so many gifted people
but Bennett Bennett Miller I've made
Moneyball with is a producer so he's
someone who's guiding me a lot and Spike
Jones and I wrote a play together and
our friends and he's helped me a lot
along the way you know very generously
and you know I just try and think of the
things that I thought were really great
about different directors that I worked
with and what I liked to hear as an
actor and you know try and give that to
the people that I'm working with most
filmmakers I've worked with like get
notes from other filmmakers or notes
from people who have done it I always
will ask like in life if I have like a
problem I'd call someone who's older
who's been through it and done it like
well and from my eyes so you ask their
advice right so I got to imagine and I
know for a fact that a lot of times that
filmmakers show their movies in their
scripts too you know people they respect
to get thoughts because I don't think
anyone's an island I don't know maybe
like the only person I imagine who I've
worked with who would probably like that
and I don't know at all I'm just
literally speculating as a fan is
Tarantino seems to like just create
these things and then you know like he
has these like magical screenplays I
don't know but I don't know maybe he has
people he leans on her or or ask for
advice I have no idea you know that man
on the Left Rowland Henin taught me why
I cook he was my mentor
it's my mentor today mentorship is such
an important part of success we continue
to mentor our staff we assign mentors we
ask you who you want your mentor to be
it's a process that we embrace all
heartedly
I started making music back in 2012 ish
I was looking for new music because I
was tired of the mainstream stuff I
wanted to find something else I would
actually like and enjoy and listen to
that discovered is a youtuber who went
by the name did in us I decided to leave
a comment on this YouTube video because
I'm very interested in learning how
those things actually work how do people
that make what we listen to or reuse
like the folks on the website graphics
music and therefore I was very
interested in like how did he do it
then we started to get in touch and even
more and more undone he started teaching
me the basics of music production now
I've got a special bonus mentorship clip
from Dan Pena that you guys are gonna
love but before that the question of the
day is I want to know who has been your
biggest virtual mentor somebody you've
never met but who you look up to or
you've learned a lot from leave it down
the comments below I'm curious if I know
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus
the system that I've seen that works
which is very much contrary to all the
other success guys which I don't
consider myself is the mentorship or if
somebody mentors you this so you find
somebody it is where you want to be and
has accomplished all this either a man
or woman and then you find them and you
come to them with your dream and your
passion and and in assuming the
chemistry's right and it's not always
right the rest is history it's like the
Tyson Gus D'Amato deal you know yeah
okay
Tyson by accident the greatest respect
Mike found that guy when he was 13 14
years old when he was you know doing all
kind of ugly things not dissimilar to
myself but the same age and and Gus
mentored him intuitive mindand as that
in you know Mike will admit I guess I
don't know I've never talked to him
about you know when when gusts died and
all that all that stuff happened
he made some poor to some very poor
decisions so you got to find that person
and you don't just you know you're not
just gonna find him you know walking
down the street on the high street I
mean you have to make a concerted effort
to find somebody that you that you you
look up to and normally that person is
several years older than you but they're
successful in what you want to do raise
your standard Apple at the core this
core value is that people passion
[Music]
now one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details